from the face of the donbass uprising to
the image of the kremlin's continued
Crackdown on critics of the special
military operation in Ukraine Igor
strilkov real name gilkin was considered
Untouchable until recently
it all changed after Wagner group's
failed Mutiny in June exposed just how
big a threat a former high-ranking
figure can be
these are people with weapons and
connected to people with weapons and so
apparently the order came from the
Kremlin from the presidential
Administration to crack down beginning
with Mr strokov Durkin who has been a
vocal critic for quite some time
strelkov became one of the first people
placed on a list of Western sanctions
against Russians
this happened after the Downing of
Malaysia Airlines flight mh17 in July
2014 by a missile over eastern Ukraine
was sentenced to Life In Absentia by a
Dutch court for his alleged involvement
as one of the commanders of the local
militia
stroke of supporters gathered outside of
Moscow Court calling for his release
he has around a million followers on
social media
when strokov lost his leadership role in
eastern Ukraine he became a harsh critic
not just of the military but of Putin as
well
he called his recently formed opposition
movement the club of angry Patriots
and his supporters believe he is one
this is completely unlawful in my point
of view now when the situation develops
in a very dramatic way after the Mutiny
when the economic situation started to
change detaining people who support the
state who support the Battlefront is
suicidal
for almost a decade ukrainians have been
calling for ego strielkov's arrest but
few believed it would be Igor's former
colleagues from the Federal Security
Service who would arrest him
Dimitri medvedenko Al Jazeera